all right guys bang-bang lunch money
time while while she's trying to get
rich the rest of us just trying to get
our lunch money right I'm here with the
beautiful intelligent planet Mara Nova I
can't really make fun of her clothes
because I not there so I don't know what
she's wearing other than it looks like a
spaghetti strap top you didn't know I
knew that did you
I don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five block five got
three products you can buy and sell
crypto under crypto exchange you can
give them crypto and I'll give you US
dollar loan to get your collateral or my
favorite product as an investor and a
user is that you can deposit crypto in a
stable coin and they will pay you ups
eight point six percent Interest go
check them out block by comm slice lunch
money no brainer get money get paid
miss Polly know what's up all right
so starting off the day with fracking
pioneer Chesapeake Energy Corporation on
Sunday became the largest oil and gas
company to file for bankruptcy
protection during the corona virus
pandemic why are they strongly you look
like an angel or a saint with the light
over your head no problem they are
struggling because Russia and Saudi
Arabia flooded the market with oil drove
down prices US shale producers can't
operate at lower than like a 30 $35 a
barrel of oil price and so they are the
second large one to go bankrupt witting
petroleum actually went bankrupt back in
April these guys profit bankruptcy
protection wiping out seven billion
dollars in debt it was the largest
they're the largest but that there's two
big ones that have gone out of business
they're gone through bankruptcy now
witting back in april they're not the
largest but they're one of the largest
and then Chesapeake is the largest you
ought to end up here a wild story
sure Aubrey McClendon was the founder of
Chesapeake Energy and he got kicked out
of the company in like 2013 2014 I
forget and then he eventually got
charged
federally with a bunch of crimes around
rigging a bunch of contracts and the day
after he was federally indicted or
charged or whatever he crashed into a
bridge at going like 90 miles an hour
and there was a bunch of speculation
over his death of whether he he killed
himself or it was an accident why do I
remember this story I feel like somebody
was somebody's mentor he was he also was
one of the owners of the Oklahoma City
Thunder and you and I know somebody who
Aubry was the largest LP and that's why
is yeah it was not a good situation but
Chesapeake Energy is filing for
bankruptcy the crazy part of this is
they're wiping out two billion dollars
worth of debt so if you're holding that
debt Kay oh I know
so Chesapeake's share price dropped more
than 93 percent since January from 172
dollars to $11.85 if you're a holding
Chesapeake stock but if you're a short
seller you did great and also the equity
probably should get wiped out here
especially if the debt holders are
getting wiped out as well but the debt
holders will some of that will convert
to equity and then also they're putting
a much more money in so like this is
what happens in bankruptcy the company
doesn't go out of business and so if you
go back weeks when we were talking about
let the airlines go to bankruptcy let
all these people go to bankruptcy the
companies don't stop operating they just
recapitalize themselves so it's just a
big myth number of bankruptcy means that
the business is gone that's not true
what's next
okay so here's one I don't actually
quite understand I don't understand how
this works but the Fed is buying up debt
of coca-cola Berkshire Hathaway Marriott
Philip Morris and Walmart why well
because this is just absolute asinine
yeah yeah so basically what ends up
happening is the Federal Reserve creates
a bunch of money right they've created
over three trillion dollars so far this
year they've expanded their balance
sheet by 75% and then what do they do
with that money so some of it is sent to
people right all kinds of different
programs they do also
lending programs but one of the other
things they can do is they can buy
assets so they can buy Treasury bonds
right they can buy ETFs they can buy all
this kind of stuff now there's a ton of
controversy and debate over what they
should buy what they shouldn't buy all
that stuff but really what's the
difference between buying a Treasury
bond which is dead
or buying a corporate bond all you're
doing is you're basically betting on the
solvency of the organization you're
buying the debt from so you're betting
on the solvency of the US when you buy a
Treasury bond you're betting on the
solvency of Walmart or coca-cola or
whoever when you buy corporate bonds so
there's a difference for sure but I
think that that one's probably blown out
of proportion in terms of if they're
gonna buy stuff like the 1i whatever why
not buy the profiles debt it's gonna be
something in a year but a lot of the
questions come down to like are you
playing kingmaker as well right is the
Federal Reserve choosing to buy
coca-cola but not Pepsi and therefore
now Pepsi suffers and coca-cola and
something better so it isn't the action
has been lauded by investors for easing
conditions and credit markets avoiding a
potentially catastrophic corporate crash
crunch cash crunch crash bunch of cash
crunch they could have triggered a wave
of bankruptcies but yeah you're right
like why coke : why not pepsi or maybe
both well of course investors are
excited about this because they're
getting bailed out there holding equity
or debt in companies that were
struggling and now the government's
coming in and this isn't quote-unquote a
bailout in the sense of there's giving
the money remember with the airlines
they just gave them five you know fifty
billion dollars and two-thirds of it was
for free this is basically a different
version of a bailout right is what
they're doing is they're buying up the
debt but somebody like me would say why
does the government have to buy it
why can't what why don't investors buy
it and the reason why investors aren't
buying is because it's mispriced
so again once again the government is
being the dummy in the room and they're
willing to do things that the private
market isn't willing to do and therefore
the companies are benefiting other
investors are benefiting and the
government's left holding the bag I just
don't agree with it whenever you read
articles and you see who's pre
using the decision make sure you you
know figure out their incentives first
big facts poorly with the big facts
alright what's next okay all right
late Saturday night a flurry of Chase
Bank customers began posting on social
media complaining of money unexpectedly
disappearing or appearing in their
accounts I feel like if money appeared
in your account you wouldn't be
complaining on social media but some one
Twitter user said check my account this
morning I'm missing over a thousand
dollars not happy
so apparently Chase had some technical
glitch that caused customers to see and
crunch balances and their accounts I
mean and they've corrected it
everybody's balance is back to normal
supposedly what were they doing with
that money well here's the scary part is
what happens if you just woke up like
mark you sources all time what happens
if you just went to the ATM and you
checked your balance and it said zero
how would you prove what money you had
in there that's a good point right it's
just numbers on the screen and if you're
like I had I had $10,000 in my bank
account and if they just said no you
didn't what would you do I don't know I
would freak the eff out right like same
thing here is just like if a thousand
dollars went missing how do you prove
that's actually what you had yeah do you
remember that story you told me about
Greece when they basically wiped out
people's uh cash in their accounts for a
tax day it's called a bank levy and what
they basically do is they just say oh
ten percent of everyone's deposits in
the bank account we're taking that as an
emergency tax for the government and
they just took out the money but even
worse than that was actually locked
people out so they couldn't withdraw any
money and so you didn't have access plus
they took some of your money and this is
something you can do but you know what
solves the problem bitcoin baby
that's what solves the problem that is
thank you you always know what your own
cuz you own the Bitcoin you hold it no
one else has access to it you've got
your private keys and so it solves all
these problems you're not worried about
JP Morgan's technical glitch you're not
worried about them saying you got less
than you
thought you had you're not worried about
anyone holding you away from your money
and you're not worried about the
government taxing it in a bank levy so
you just need to keep track of your key
private keys but but okay if somebody
wiped out all your Bitcoin how are we
gonna prove you I guess there's no party
to go to they can't they can't wipe it
out the only thing they could do they
could hack you and steal it just take it
like for some cuz you're in charge
I like being in charge let's go okay all
right so okay so work from home forever
is that all these companies are now
telling workers basically you can just
like working home permanently even after
the pandemic and of course the companies
are Facebook Twitter square Shopify
French automaker PSA I don't know box
slack so it's mostly um tech startups
but honestly I feel like they were
already kind of distributed and they
were already working remotely this is
not anything new it's just kind of like
let's get some positive press yeah I
mean for sure there's people who are
just seeking positive press there's also
people who say hey look why do we need
all these offices right we can do all
this stuff remotely as well and look
it'll probably end up being not black
and white in the sense that some
companies will do really well no thrive
some companies will struggle with the
the transition but ultimately I think
what the pandemic has shown is that you
don't need everyone in the same room
100% of the time the whole idea of like
punching a time clock to go to work is
pretty stupid and then on top of that
like if you can optimize remotely your
employees actually may be happier right
there they'll actually be able to live
where they want to live and kind of have
a bunch of freedom that previously was
unavailable to them so like good for
these companies doing it I was um I was
actually reading an article that said
that people are actually more productive
working from home a lot of companies are
finding that and it probably has to do
with your not commuting for an hour to
you know you're not constant like where
I used to sit up fortunate people would
walk by me all day long so you get
distracted I mean all
that is and then those pointless
meetings so this way maybe is just a
little bit better for some people
um yeah but if you work but if you work
from home and you have an annoying wife
and she just keeps bothering you 95
percent of the time I'm is it worse to
sit next to people walking by or just
have her be able to yell to you hey hey
I so my mom was like how did Anthony
survive 3 months with you every single
day I was like you know why he's lucky
to be there but another another Park
from another perk from working in the
home is it also allows flexibility for
parents who have little kids and they
are able to do their work while also
take care of the kid and not have to pay
for daycare and all of that stuff so I
think you're saying that like it's a
positive there's a lot of parents were
saying I wish my kid was back at daycare
I wish they were in school is I know I'm
not trying to happen I'm not trying to
have two year-old Johnny pulling on my
pant leg hitting me with dad can I eat
now dad can I eat now oh my god next huh
okay yo you look almost as pretty as I
do today prettier okay now so this is my
favorite story of all time
NASA is offering thirty five thousand
dollars in prizes for someone to design
a toilet that will work on the moon like
first of all shouldn't we design other
things before the toilet first I'm cool
with designing the toilets on in the
moon why only thirty five thousand
dollars I want a million dollars if I do
that I feel like I feel like Bill Gates
is earning on this he's probably
designed like three toilets I know and I
just feel like if I was gonna design a
toilet that worked on the moon or in
space I wouldn't go do it in the grant
program for NASA instead I would take
the technology I could create a company
and then I'd say hey you guys wanted to
contract me and I got a business and
instead I would tell them you need to
pay me thirty-five thousand dollars per
toilet I give you and in the government
contracting process that'll probably fly
just perfectly but you know what's
really tough you need to design a toilet
that works both
micro in the microgravity of space or
zero-g and on the moon where gravity is
about 1/6 of what we feel on earth so I
feel like that's pretty just need to
have like a like a like a vacuum like a
little vacuum suction remember everyone
who doesn't know poop on the spacecraft
or saved until they get back to earth
they just research on lunch money
remember end P number one not number two
number one is thrown out into space they
just let the P float into space wait
crazy yeah what's not crazy what do you
mean if you go for a spacewalk it means
you're just hanging out in pee infested
space I think I think I think it's gone
by then maybe okay what's up this is
what I like bonus points will be awarded
to designs that can capture vomit
without requiring the crew member to put
his or her head in the toilet I feel
like that should be designed for Earth -
really that's a good invention to have I
feel like NASA is doing a lot of
dreaming and they should just focus on
some more realistic thing it sounds
pretty ridiculous on they should focus
on helping me win my bet and prepare Tom
Cruise to go to space that's what's the
next what's the next topic the next
topic is lunch money winner so on Friday
we asked for people to put nice comments
in my day you were kind to your friend
in point and plena was gonna choose a
winner but before she says who the
winner is I just want to point out that
she texted me on Friday afternoon and
hit me with Wow people really liked
today's video they're being so nice in
the comments and I had to remind her
that in a effect they were getting paid
to be nice in the comments and that's
why there was nice comments not because
they just liked her all the time once I
realized that it was kind of sad but
then I think some people genuinely liked
my joke I don't think the joke was funny
I literally didn't laugh all right who's
the lunch money winner
okay the lunch money winner is Harris
King he said Paul you know we'll
probably have a billion 1 billion dollar
net worth worth Paul I've been cool with
that guys the first time can I tell them
I already know what story you can tell
go ahead he said I said I said something
about George Clooney and a mall and and
somebody said I think a mall is like
more famous than he is or something like
more successful than he is is what they
said and Anthony said I love it if my
wife was worse or if I was known as
somebody's husband well I'm not telling
what is it you're not telling it right
but basically if my wife was more
successful than I was of course nothing
no you said you'd like to be known as
somebody referred to as somebody's
husband like oh yes if somebody was like
oh that's plane as husband and awesome
I'm in that means that you're super
successful why would I not like that
good Oh thumbs up thumbs up
that was like a two thumbs up type
comment but okay that's fine I'll go
with one thumbs up that's fine all right
what's your G
Harris thanks for your [ __ ] today
but you wait how are we gonna get in
touch with Harris now I'll leave a
comment down there and tell them a
secret code to tell me yeah
can you please tell me what joke you
have so I know it's gonna be something
not funny so it's time for polina's joke
time okay was a look of I can't wait
okay what do you call a pig that does
karate
that does karate a Squealer no no ruin
the joke with bad answers a pork chop
it's so good come on I was the answer
yes it's a pork chop well first of all
we know you don't do karate with that
move that's fine yeah I don't know it
looks more like you're a blender than
doing any karate chops over there but
I'm glad that you said joke I'm very
glad that you thought that joke was
funny good good job Hey
all right guys that's it I hope you
enjoy playing as jokes don't go bankrupt
if you want $35,000 go figure out how to
build a toilet from the moon and we'll
see you guys tomorrow
lunch money wash he's trying to get rich
to rest so it's just trying to get lunch
money right be nice in the comments
again I like that bang bang
hope you guys enjoyed this episode of
lunch money as much as we did
don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block v so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on I'm an investor a
user and a huge fan what you're a bigger
fan of block fire than you are of me
block wise my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina
they've got three products they can give
you a US dollar loan you can earn up to
eight point six percent interest on an
interest-bearing account or you can buy
and sell crypto currencies on their
crypto exchange I personally use the
interest-bearing account there's not
very many places where you'll find up to
eight point six percent interest on a
deposit in an interest-bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6% it's pretty
compelling so click on the link in the
description say thanks to the folks that
block bye
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy plane in the comment and we'll see
you guys tomorrow and be kind to your
friends